today I'm going to take you in the gym
and share with you what I do so when I
work out in the gym I'll typically spend
about an hour I like to stop my warmup
on the treadmill you can choose any
other cardio machines of your choice do
a quick 5 to 10 minutes warm-up start
slow and gradually increase your speed
and pace it is very important to get
your muscles warmed up in order to have
an effective training session plus we do
not want any injuries
so my fat burning gym routine is going
to combine superset training and also
cardio training it is the most efficient
and fastest way to burn fat and build
lean muscles once I'm all warmed up I'm
going to start at a strength training
area for the first circuit I'm going to
combine a goblet squat with in and out
jumps so find a way you're comfortable
with and slowly progress by lifting
heavier I'm lifting about 16 kilos stand
shoulder width apart slowly squat as
slow as you can and push yourself back
up with your heels always keep your back
straight chest open and engage your core
don't slouch or collapse your shoulders
doing that would put too much strain on
your lower back so this workout it works
your entire legs and also core so I'm
doing each exercise for 45 seconds with
15 seconds rests in between then it's
straight to in and out jumps start by
standing in a sumo squat position jump
in and back into a sumo squat make sure
you're squatting low and touching the
floor again keep your back straight
chest open and engage your core you will
start to feel your legs burning in your
heart pumping back to goblet squat it's
going to be a total of eight intervals
back to back with a very short rest in
between to keep my heart rate constantly
elevated so one superset will take 8
minutes long it's time to hit the
treadmill I'm going to run for 4 minutes
long and increase the gradient and every
minute adjust the speed according to
your pace so for the first minute I'm
starting at 0% gradients on the second
minute I'm
twisting it to 3% gradient you can
either maintain your current speed which
will force your legs to work a lot
harder or decrease the speed very
slightly on the 3rd minute increased by
another 3 more percent to 6 percent
gradients I'm going to reduce my speed
slightly this increase of gradient is
basically similar to running uphill and
on the final minute let's bring it up to
9% gradient it's the final minute
so keep running keep pushing yourself
and don't stop until the very end I'm
going to catch a quick one-minute
breather keep myself hydrated and it's
back to strength training so I'm going
to work on my chest and back it's going
to be a combination of bent over row and
deadlift with push up and twist grab a
pair of dumbbells go for a moderately
heavy weight I'd say between 6 to 10
kilos each you want to really work your
muscles but at the same time you're able
to maintain the workout for four sets
Stan sugar with the pot keep your knees
soft and Bend slightly from your waist
pull the dumbbells close to your belly
and squeeze your back muscles then
engage your core straighten your body
with a slight arch to work on your lower
back muscles repeat for 45 seconds and
is straight to push up and twist so keep
your palms shoulder-width apart in line
with your chest lower your body push
yourself back up and twist to the right
repeat and twist to the left the
twisting motion will engage your core to
keep your balance so do this for 45
seconds rest for 15 seconds in between
and repeat the two exercises back to
back for a total of eight intervals it's
time to get back onto the treadmill this
time I'm gonna do speed interval running
so I'm starting the first minute by
sprinting at my fastest speed remember
to pace your breathing to help you run
faster and longer then bring the speed
down to either a slow jog or walk and
recover on the second minute take this
minute to really catch your breath
breathe deeply and bring your heart rate
down slightly on the first minute I'm
increasing the speed back into sprinting
feel the burn feel your heart rate
pumping
focus on your goal and keep running now
let's bring the speed down again on the
final minute and slowly recover for the
third superset I'm going to work on my
shoulders and arms it's a combination of
bicep curls to show the press and bench
dips grab a pair of lightweights
dumbbells I'll say between three to five
kilos each and lift heavier as you
progress curl up engage your biceps
twist and press the widths up to work on
your shoulders keep your posture upright
and avoid swing your body don't rush the
movements break the moves down and
you'll be working your muscles even more
so let's do that for 45 seconds and rest
now I'm going to use a weight bench and
place one dumbbell on the floor to
perform elevated bench dips so place
your hands close to you flat on the
bench with your fingers pointed forward
lower your body down slowly until your
elbows are 90 degrees breathe out as you
push yourself back up remember to always
keep your elbows close to your side and
as you lower yourself your body should
always stay close to the bench so I'm
having both feet elevated to increase
the difficulty of the workout you can
start by placing both feet on the ground
and keep your knees slightly bended
that's one set done three more to go
if you struggle towards the last few
wraps use your bodyweight momentum to
help you push the dumbbells up it's good
to struggle to words or the last few
wraps this means you have really pushed
your muscles to their best efforts if
it's too easy
it means your weights a too light it's
time to hit the treadmill for another
four minutes I'm going to repeat incline
interval running even if I'm running at
a slower pace Inc I'm running is a lot
tougher it activates more muscles which
also means more calories being burned
one final stupas at let's work on the
core I'm going to combine 1/2 V tucks
with spider-man plank place both arms on
the ground to support your upper body
keep both legs straight lift them off
the ground and slowly lower them back
down
repeat you'll feel your lower abs
engaged again do this for 45 seconds
with 15 seconds rest before moving on to
spider-man plank this is my favorite
move for killer apps start in a high
plank position bring your right knee
forward towards your elbow return and
repeat on the other side now let's
repeat both exercises for three more
sets I'm going to end the work out with
another speed interval running this is
the final set start and sprint at your
best speed if you struggle to run for a
long period of time break your run into
many sets it is just as effective to end
my workout I'm going to cool down with
some stretches for about 10 minutes so
remember to keep breathing and bring
your heart rate back down now that's a
solid one our workouts don't feel
intimidated by the weights I want you to
take this workout to the gym and add
this into your routine for best result
do this two to three times weekly on
alternate days so be sure to take
pictures of yourself in the gym and tank
me at Uranus are official are the best
[Music]
you